je vais vous faire une confidence
j'ai aucun talent et j'ai pas vraiment
de pression non plus
quand j'avais 12 ans une de mes
meilleures copines s'appelait virginie
et elle elle était passionnée
d'équitation elle était hyper doué
et moi je me sentais un peu nul à côté
alors je me suis mise à passer mon
premier galop 2e 3e et au bout d'un an
j'ai arrêté ça marchait pas
une hotte de la bande elle avait un
appareil dentaire et elle avait l'air
hyper poule avec son appareil dentaire
alors j'avais pris mes petites épingles
à cheveux cd chignon de danseuse et je
les mettais sur mes dents
et je me souviens aussi par exemple
quand j'avais rendez vous chez
l'ophtalmo je faisais exprès de
transformer l'eau en q où le cul en haut
pour être sûr pouvoir porter des
lunettes moi aussi
rétrospectivement je vous rends compte
que j'avais besoin peut-être un peu me
faire remarquer et surtout pour autre
chose que juste la petite fille qui a
perdu son papa
de fil en aiguille j'ai poursuivi des
études sans encombre et j'ai atterri en
école de commerce en laissant porter
à la fin j'ai terminé par un stage aux
états unis dans une maison d'édition en
marketing
assez rapidement je me rends compte que
le marketing c'est finalement pas
vraiment fait pour moi et que ce ne sera
pas le cas non plus ni chez l'oréal ni
chez procter & gamble alors que pourtant
c'est la voie toute tracée non j'ai une
meilleure idée je vais monter une maison
d'édition à ce moment là j'ai 21 ans et
ça n'a pas marché
je rentre à paris je rentre à paris et
je me dis bon j'ai pas le courage j'ai
pas la confiance en moi suffisante pour
chercher un job ça me paraît le bout du
monde envoyez 112 cv passé 112 entretien
et me faire blake blessant douze fois
j'en suis pas capable donc je vais
prendre moins de risques et je me dis
que je vais créer mon propre job
un job qui va me permettre de pouvoir
déjeuner avec mes copines qui va me
pouvoir permettre d'aller leur maison
quand j'ai envie de les changer mes
fringues chez zara
un job où je maîtrise finalement la
chaîne de bout en bout je vais monter ma
boîte
alors j'ai toujours pas de passion
j'ai pas d'idée non plus
donc je vais à la fnac rayon
développement personnel développement
d'entreprises et là j'achète une dizaine
de livres
spécialisés le business plan pour les
nuls
bon en revanche j'arrive à saisir
l'opportunité de partir en chine à ce
moment là donc j'ai 22 ans on est en
2000 2006 et je pars en chine avec un
ami à la foire de canton alors la foire
de canton qu'est ce que c'est c'est un
immense salon dans lequel tous les
industriels chinois se regroupent pour
présenter les produits qui peuvent créer
alors ça va des cachemires en passant
par des chaussons d'hôtel des briquets
etc etc et je me dis finalement c'est la
base du commerce j'achète un jeu
vendeuse est a priori je suis pas plus
débile que d'autres n'y a pas de raison
j'y arrive pas donc je pars là bas en
chine et je fais les 1200 stands les uns
après les autres avec une petite valise
vide à la recherche de la bonne idée baj
sans doute m'inspirer moi qui suis pas
très inspirante
donc je parle et à la buvette je tombe
sur un produit une machine au mur un
distributeur automatique de lingettes
pour se laver les mains et c'est vrai
qu'on a tous toujours les mains un peu
dégueulasse finalement c'était avant le
h1n1 l'intuition d'entrepreneurs et je
me dis que là j'ai l'idée du siècle je
prends en photo la petite étiquette sur
le côté avec le nom du fabricant je
reviens à paris
et là en cinq jours je crée la plaquette
commerciale je contacte trois hôpitaux
je commande de prototype pour 500 euros
et c'est parti je deviens distribuer de
distributrices pardon de leur jette pour
se laver les mains alors malheureusement
quand j'ai reçu les premiers prototypes
la machine était trop fragile pour être
dans des lieux publics
donc ça n'a pas marché non plus
et ça faisait quelques mois que j'avais
dit à tout le monde que je monte ma
boîte savez la fameuse question dans les
dîners en ville qu'est ce que tu fais
dans la vie
et je sentais à chaque fois ce regard
plein de sous-entendus les entrepreneurs
comprendront ce regard qui veut dire oui
c'est mignon mais vivement que l'on
passe un peu aux choses sérieuses et
c'est ce regard là justement qui a été
mon driver je me suis posé pendant 15
jours sur mon canapé et je me suis dit
que j'avais quinze jours pour trouver
l'idée alors je regardais autour de moi
qu'est ce qui manque qu'est ce qui
serait utile quel produit j'ai pas
encore dont j'aurai besoin et tout à
coup je me suis souvenu d'un site que
j'utilisais quand j'habitais new york
pour réserver ma table en ligne si
l'appel opentable et c'est vrai qu'en
2007 en france on pouvait tout réserver
sur internet sauf un restaurant ça
c'était mon idée de génie ce thème est
deuxième idée du siècle
c'est ce que j'ai fait j'ai contacté
opentable je me suis fait passer pour un
restaurateur qui voulait ouvrir 20
restauratrice pardon qui voulait ouvrir
un restaurant à new york pour comprendre
comment il fonctionnait combien ça
coûtait c'était quoi cette histoire de
logiciels chez les restos etc et j'ai eu
la chance d'avoir pendant 30 minutes une
super des modules logiciels
alors comme j'avais fait dix ans de
piano et je maîtrisais pas trop mal la
marche turque contrôler ses comptes
relevé copies d'écran contrôler ces
contrôles des copies d'écran ce qui m'a
permis de créer finalement le cahier des
charges et c'est parti en 2007
je crée restopolitan
on a eu cinq premières années
fantastiques
notre premier client c'était le georges
5 à paris
le deuxième c'était le groupe elior
entre 2007 et 2010 on a levé un peu plus
d'un million et demi d'euros
avec un pool d'investisseurs
assez sensationnel xavier niel marc
simoncini jacques antoine granjon on
avait des dizaines des dizaines de
coupures de presse on a une demi page
dans le figaro donc on était assez fier
le soir quand je me couchais en revanche
je savais que quelque chose n'allait pas
on était toujours pas rentable
les restaurateurs finalement était pas
prêt à acheter concrètement ce produit
et on faisait plus d'évangélisation de
commercialisation
ce qui était très pesant pour moi c'est
le sentiment d'imposture que j'avais un
sentiment d'imposture parce que j'avais
ces regards sur moi et c'était des
regards pleins d'admiration
et moi je savais en fait que ça marchait
pas on avait été cinq fois interdit
banque de france
tous les jours ça sonnait à la porte du
bureau c'était pas les clients un jour
c'était le facteur pour un recommandé le
lendemain c'était lui sied un jour le
facteur le lendemain lui sied mais
j'avais déjà une équipe de huit
personnes et j'avais pas envie de les
laisser tomber
donc je me suis dit j'ai 48 heures pour
trouver une autre idée repartir à zéro
et je vais entraîner mon équipe avec moi
on avait trois mois pour être rentable
je me suis posé je me suis déjà un qui
tu es
petite confidence une nouvelle fois j'ai
un quart de sang vosgien à 4 200
aveyronnais et la moitié juif
aveyronnais donc finalement les sites
internet où ce qui est un peu virtuel
est pas très terre à terre c'était pas
mon truc donc il fallait qu'on crée un
produit physique parce qu'avec mon
équipe on s'était dit si on doit tous
descendre dans la rue pour le vendre
dans des kermesses a sorti des théâtres
un produit physique on arrivera à le
vendre on a regardé un petit peu le
marché à ce moment là il y avait
l'explosion de la thématique bons plans
restaurant avec des sujets comme les la
fourchette les groupes les coffrets
cadeaux deux problématiques qu'on avait
remarqué la première du côté du
restaurateur ou finalement être associés
juste un pourcentage de réduction
c'était assez dévalorisant et l'autre
problématique du côté du consommateur
ou l'expérience client était pas
toujours optimales optimale c'est pas
valable tous les jours c'est compliqué
de réserver le coffret qui se périment
et on est parti de ce postulat là pour
créer la carte de membre reste poli
thann donc on était fin 2011 alors
l'huissier lui continué toujours à
ce nez à la porte j'étais un peu plus
détendu vais au bout de la dixième fois
quand on lui ouvre on est un peu plus à
l'aise
et là j'ai dit à mon équipe on a un seul
objectif c'est de faire sur les 12
prochains mois un million d'euros de
chiffre d'affaires
c'était cinq ans qu on plafonne à 150000
donc c'était un bel objectif
1 millions d'euros chiffre d'affaires
c'est quoi ces quatre-vingt mille euros
par mois et ses 2500 euros par jour et
on est revenu à ce chiffre unique super
pragmatique il faut que tous les jours
on fasse 2500 euros de chiffre
d'affaires et donc on s'est mis à
distribuer la carterie sopo l'hythane
auprès des entreprises alors la carte
reste pettan aujourd'hui qu'est ce que
c'est ça permet à son détenteur de
bénéficier d'un repas offert qui est
directement déduit l'addition par le
restaurateur à condition de venir
minimum à deux et il ya un service de
conciergerie donc toutes les
problématiques qu'on ait pu analyser
auprès des autres produits existants on
avait réussi à les anéantir
je suis très fier de mon équipe parce
qu'en effet au bout de 12 mois on a
réussi à faire un million d'euros de
chiffre d'affaires et la deuxième année
on en a fait deux et depuis on est à 4
g 30 he
j'ai 31 ans et la route est encore
longue
j'ai 31 ans et déjà un petit garçon qui
s'appelle paul et qui a cinq mois
il pèse 9 kilos et demi
et paul a commencé ses premières purée
mercredi la purée de carotte
c'est une chance quand on est
entrepreneur de pouvoir déménager ses
bureaux à 100 mètres de chez soi il ya
deux mois c'est ce que j'ai fait je suis
venu lui donner moi même sa première
purée
j'ai regardé l'heure à laquelle j'en
voyais mon dernier mile hier soir il
était 5h30 8
et c'est pas parce que mon fils fait pas
ses nuits
c'est parce que j'aime ce que je fais
et c'est ça la plus belle opportunité à
saisir